[Music]
one of the astounding facts of our time
is the gusher of wealth going to the
very top of the wealth distribution in
the world it's mind-boggling
mind-boggling to think of Jeff Bezos for
example with a net worth personally
individual net worth of hold on to your
chair how about a hundred sixty three
billion dollars that's that's a lot of
money it's I'm myself an Amazon a user I
think it's a awfully good service and
product that he's developed but a
hundred sixty three billion dollars in a
world where a lot of his workers
struggle to get by a lot of the people
in Seattle where Amazon is headquartered
our homeless where there are incredible
needs that for a tiny fraction of that
wealth could keep millions of kids alive
and in school you have to say alright
world economy is dynamic but it's not
really exactly fair and it's not really
oriented towards addressing everyone's
basic human rights and needs what's
happened to the wealth at the top it's
amazing
back in 2006 there were about 700
billionaire's or so that's was a lot and
they had a net worth if you added up all
of their stocks and bonds and other
assets of something on the order of
about three trillion dollars and I would
sit there and say oh my god can you
imagine this and in just a dozen years a
dozen years even in a dozen years with a
mega financial crisis in between the
billionaires
went from about 700 or so to now 2208 on
the most recent Forbes magazine list of
billionaires and their net worth went
from around 3 trillion which was
absolutely mind-boggling to begin with
to nine point one trillion dollars at
the start of 2018 when Forbes published
the list and now almost surely well
above 10 trillion dollars including this
phenomenal wealth of mr. B's o--'s know
richest person in the world but many
others now Bill Gates who is far and
away the world's leading philanthropist
because he was long the richest person
in the world and he and Melinda Gates
very rightly generously wisely boldly in
a visionary way said we're gonna give
this away I created the biggest
foundation in the world the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation they've been
putting in several billion dollars a
year to fighting disease and doing a
fantastic job but consider this in 2010
Bill Gates called on other billionaires
join in and make a pledge called a
Giving Pledge to give away at least half
of your wealth during your lifetime and
Bill Gates took that pledge himself at
that point his net worth was about 50
billion dollars he's been giving away
roughly 4 billion a year since then and
you might think his net worth has gone
down a bit given that generosity but his
net worth now is 93 billion dollars so
the wealth is such a gusher that you can
give billions away and it just keeps
growing and growing and growing beyond
anything that most of us mortals can
even imagine what I know as a an
economist
that has worked all over the world
including in the poorest places in the
world
little bits can save lives and make
futures for the children of this world
and unbelievably low cost and it just
gets me that we have ten trillion
dollars here and we have kids who are
hungry dying and out of school over here
and can't we make the connection and the
answer is we have to so my thought is at
a minimum 10 trillion come on put in at
least 1% that's such a tiny amount
because your wealth grows it much more
than that put in 1 percent of your net
worth per year minimum to help the kids
1% of 10 trillion is a hundred billion
dollars and if you take out your paper
and pencil or your Excel spreadsheet you
can show that for a hundred billion
dollars a year 1% of the net worth of
just 2208 individuals you could get
every kid in school all the way through
upper secondary education and you could
establish universal health coverage for
everybody in every low-income country in
the world that's a pretty good gig for
2208 people but they got to get on with
it I think they have enough yachts
enough mansions enough of everything and
it's really time for that wealth to be
deployed for the purposes of our
generation of children who utterly and
desperately need it and I say do it
voluntarily or if you don't do it
voluntarily fine we'll put on a levy an
SDG levy a sustainable development goal
levy of 1% of your net worth because
we're gonna get this job done we're
gonna get every child health care we're
gonna get every time
all into school
[Music]
you